نفت القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه سيطره
روسيا على بلده سوليدار شرق البلاد واكدت
استمرار المعارك العنيفه وكانت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه قد اعلنت السيطره الكامله
على مدينه سوليدار وقالت ان السيطر عليها
ستسمح بقطع الامدادات عن القوات
الاوكرانيه في بحث وبانها خطوه حاسمه في
العمليات الهجوميه في اوكرانيا
في مساء الثانيه عشر من يناير تم تحرير
مدينه سوليدار وهو امر مهم لاستمرار
العمليات الهجوميه الناجحه في اتجاه
دونيزتك ان فرده سيطره الكامله على سوريا
يجعلوا من الممكن قطع طرق الامداد للقوات
الاوكرانيه في مدينه باخموت الواقعه الى
الجنوب الغربي السيطره على سردار جاءت بعد
قصف كثير لطيران الجيش والقوات الصاروخيه
والمدفعيه التي ركزتنيرانها على مواقع
القوات الاوكرانيه في المدينه ومنعت بذلك
نقل الاحتياطات والذخيره واجبرت العدو على
الانسحاب لخطوط دفاع اخرى العمليات
الهجوميه الناجحه لقواتنا في سوليدار خلال
الايام الثلاثه الماضيه اسفرت عن مقتل
اكثر من 700 جندي اوكراني وتدمير اكثر من
300 قطعه سلاح تابعه للقوات الاوكرانيه
يا ضمي اليمين دول الناس في الان مراسل
العربيه رائد الاغبر رائد اهلا وسهلا بك
نحاول تساقط مزيد من الاخبار من رائد
بتعرف المعلومات متضاربه جدا موسكو اكدت
اليوم السيطره الكامله على سوليدار همم
كيف مازال التنفي وتقول ان المعارك ما
زالت مستمرات مع اعترافها بان الوضع صعب
اولا اخر المعلومات المتوفر لديك هل
السيطره الروسيه كامله على سوليدار ام لا
يعني
المعارك ما زالت دائره في محيط وليده
طالب مساء الخير بالفعل اعلنت الدفاع
الروسيه اليوم بعد صمت طويل ثلاثه ايام من
الاعلام من ارض المعركه من قبل القوات
باقدر من قبل السلطات المحليه والمقاتلين
عن السيطره الكامله لكن موسكو تري وصبرت
وحتى الكريم الان قال لا نريد التعجل
بالاعلان على السيطره الكامله حتى تتم
بالكامل اليوم اعلنت الدفاع السيطره
الكامله واظهرت صور وفيديوهات لمقاتلين ان
يتجولون في مناطق مختلفه من احياء سوليدار
اضافه الى صور يعني بشعه لقتله اوكرانيين
من ارض المعركه المعلومات من هناك تشير
الى ان عمليات التنظيف مال زالت جاريه
طالب عمليات التطهير كما يسمونها من همم
يعني همم فلول الجيش الاوكراني المتبقيه
او المغتبئه في السراديب وفي الانفاق وفي
الخنادق وفي همم يعني مناجم الملح
المنتشره في تلك البلده خاصه في المناطق
الغربيه لكن ال- ال-
الروايه الاوكرانيه بانها ماذا لا تقاوم
بالفعل هناك قصف اوكرانيا على مدينه
سليدار لكنها من خارج الحدود الاداريه
لتلك المنطقه اي منطقه همم شرحت في اا
يعني مداخله سابقه بان حتى الامام وحتى
صفات تبع المناطق التي تقول اوكرانيا
بانها سيطرت عليها ما زالت تحت
ني رعيه الروسيه همم ليست هناك منطقه همم
حسمت بالكامل لكن يستطيع احد الاطراف ان
يسيطر على حدود المنطقه عسكريه وان يتحصن
من نيران الطرف الاخر بالفعل همم اعلنت
ايضا عن استطاعتها الان تطبيق مدينه باخ-
المجاوره وهي الهدف الرئيس طالب الهدف
الرئيس ومدينه الاكبر المطله او المدخل
على المدن الكبرى
كرمبي لاحقا كل هذه المدن مدخلها هو فاطمه
فاطمه
المشاهدين ارجو ان تعيد ما تقول انت تقول
تاكد همم ان همم
محاصره من قبل القوات الروسيه بعد السيطره
هل هذا المعلومات مؤكده
الحديث عن الحصار من ثلاثه اطراف قالت
يعني القوات الروسيه ترغب بمحافظه خلال
اشهر طويله حوالي ثلاثه اشهر ايضا
حاولت محاصره باطمه من الناحيه الجنوبيه
واكتمل الحصار من الناحيه الشرقيه وارادوا
ان يكمل الحصار ليصبح على شكل هلال من
الناحيه الشماليه لكنهم تعرقلوا
بمقاومه من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه في
سردار فاصبح عليهم حتما يعني الوصول الى
سندار والسيطر عليها من اجل اكمال الطوق
على باقمك لان سيدار تعتبر مدينه صغيره او
بلده اذا قررناها مع فاطمه
خلال هذه الفتره تمت السيطره ودحره الجيش
الروسي كما يقول القوات الاوكرانيه الى
الخلف من ناحيه الغربيه وسيطر على الناحيه
الشماليه ليكمل نصف الدائره ابقى نصف
الطوق على القوات الاوكرانيه المتمركز في
وهي الهدف الرئيس والان طبعا هناك عمليات
اقتحام تجري همم من اطراف متعدده من مدينه
محاولات اقتحام للدخول الى اطراف المدينه
من الناحيه الجنوبيه والجنوبيه الشرقيه
قبل الوصول الى الناحيه الشماليه التي
ستبدا منها اقتحامات جنوبا وشمالا طالب
بالنسبه الى سيرفس الى اي مدى يعني هذه
المنطقه مهمه وعندما نتحدث عن سيرفر نتحدث
عن مدينه نتحدث عن اقليم نتحدث عن ماذا
نشرح للمشاهدين رائد
جميل الحديث طالب عن
لنعود بالذكرى الى ااا يعني سيطرت القوات
الروسيه على اخر معاقل الجيش الاوكراني في
مقاطعه لوغانس واكمال السيطره على مقاطعه
لوغانستانس
الى بلده سيرفس نحن لا نستطيع ان نقول
المدينه لانها صغيره بالفعل انسحبوا الى
بلده سيفر لان لها امتدادات عسكريه الى
سوليدار والى باخنه لذلك تمركز الجيش
الاوكراني في سوليدار وكانت الانقلاب
بعدها بان همم بدا الجيش الاوكراني يعني
يعود ادراجه في بعض المناطق مثل الايمان
كذا وكان هناك يعني فطور في الحراك
العسكري الروسي مع عوده
الجانب الروسي الى سابق عهده من التقدم في
المناطق الشماليه خاصه
نعم اصبحت هناك همم رغبه بالانقراض من
منطقه ليس الشانز في مقاطعه همم على بلده
ومع سيطره الجيش الروسي على لسانس لانها
تشق الطريق ما
بينزله الا اي من الناحيه الغربيه وكذلك
باقي اصبحت منعزله الا من الناحيه الغربيه
على الابتداء في العمق الاخراني من دون
اسم راس العربيه رائد الاغبر شكرا جزيلا
لك رائد على كل هذه المعلومات
[موسيقى]